저희가 이번에 중대형 빌딩 매각
주관사를 도전해 보려고 합니다 저희가
다른 주간사와 다른
4가지의 특징을 가지고 있습니다
첫 번째로 저희는 매각하는 건물의
스토리텔링을 할 겁니다 제가 예를
들어서 와인 같은 경우에도
어떤 스토리가 있느냐에 따라서
맛이라든지 가격이라든지 이런게 차이가
많이 나잖아요
빌딩을
단순하게 가격이랑 임대료로 가치를
평가한게 아니라 그 건물의 위치라든지
건축사님의 설계 스토리
등을 토대로
빌딩의 스토리텔링을 찾으려고 노력을
할 것이고
스토리텔링을이
빌딩 매각 자료에 담을 것입니다 두
번째 저희는 퀄리티 높은 영상을
제작할 겁니다
A4 용지에이 빌딩의 가치를 정확히
표현할 수가 없습니다 중대형 빌딩
같은 경우에는 더더욱 그렇습니다
그래서 저희는
드론 촬영뿐만 아니라
퀄리티 높은 영상을 제작해서이 영상만
봐도이 빌딩의 가치를
수 있도록 퀄리티 높은 영상을
제작하도록 하겠습니다 그 세 번째
공사하기 전 신축부지나 아니면 낡은
건물 같은 경우에는 저희가 공사를
하고 난 뒤에 모습을 3d로 만들어서
매수인 분들한테 보여드리도록
하겠습니다 그래서 앱이 매수자분들이
오시면 같이 vr을 착용해서 마치
공사가 완료된 다음에 모습을
눈에 그릴 수 있도록 저희가 3d로
직접 제작해서
다른 업체와 차별화된 서비스를 제공해
드리도록 하겠습니다 그리고 마지막으로
bsn 그룹의 빌딩에 관심있는
분들의 팔로우가 약 15만 명이
넘습니다 그래서 저희가
유튜브라든지
블로그 페이스북 페이지 등
여러가지 SNS 활동을 하고 있고 그
어떤 매체보다
홍보가 더 확실히 될 것이라고 저는
생각이 좀 들고요
외국인 버전도 만들고 있어서 나중엔
외국 업체한테도 브리핑 될 수 있게
준비를 하고 있습니다 그래서 저희한테
매각 주관사를 맡겨주시면 저희 b
sm만의
특징을 잘 살려서
최단기간에 매각을 진행해 드리고
여러분들이 만족하는 금액을 받을 수
있도록 최선을 다하도록 하겠습니다
저희 bsn의 매각 주관사를 맡겨
주시기 바랍니다
[음악]